whoa
it's maurice ashley what's up maurice
you're reading at a good time or kind of
uh
an interesting time i'm in darkness
right now
okay here we go oh this is great timing
okay people are figuring it out
beautiful
so
yeah where everyone can uh can vote now
and the beauty of this is
we have the moves displayed on stream
maybe i can add the chat on stream too
so maybe for those i'm sure most people
can figure out what's going on right now
but i'm playing against chat
and they're the request is that people
go into uh to stafford
so okay
this might be a little bit hectic but
we'll try and make it work
uh
okay beautiful beautiful or overwhelming
i don't know the right adjective
but okay i think we're good are we good
hopefully we're good okay so for gamma
time
so uh the way to vote is just typing the
move in chat
and if there's too many trolls and we'll
put it in sub only mode
but looks like we're going into
a stafford
oh some yeah some moves get cut off i
guess
okay haven't done this in a while
perspective oh do people want me to flip
the board
like this is this better or worse
we could run a poll everyone's saying
their moves so it's hard to
gauge what people want better better
let's do a poll
white's perspective wait which
perspective
white which is what we have right now or
black
or i'm actually curious i don't care
okay we're doing a quick poll um
staff for gamba time
oh okay most people want their own
perspective that's fine
i don't really mind same position either
way right
oh this is interesting so like d3
d3 h3 knight c3
key2 is up there
i'm going to play my usual preparation
also if you vote for king e2 you get
banned so please don't
i'll have to put mods to work
please play reasonably
bishop b2 okay i'll play
h5 i'm trying not to say like too much
to like influence
chat at least now king king e2 is
illegal so that's good
yeah this is actually really really
interesting we see the hive mind in
action
um we'll see if chad can refute my staff
or gambit
um
wait a minute i played stafford gamut
against chat in the past
i remember the game
i played queen d6 i'm gonna play a
different move this time i'm gonna play
queen
d4
hitting upon
and the thread is pretty clear
okay
oh there's a prediction too so much shot
participation
people can influence
wait a minute people can
wager channel points but also
influence some moves i feel like people
could easily rig this
but i don't want to give anyone ideas
um oh this is funny this is the move
carlson played i showed this in a recent
video
this is not a good move even though
carlson played it because it loses the
pawn
but it does defend against f2 so could
be worse
have to remember what i showed
or maybe chad will remember for me
okay so yeah that's very logical good
job chad saving the rook
not taking the bishop even though
probably some people wanted to
um so i'll take here
wow so basically in this moment we can
see how many trolls there are
uh thankfully most people most people do
recapture
good job i'm so proud so so proud
of at least most of you so this is still
preparation i showed this exact line
within the past week and now i play
queen
e5 and this is all my preparation from
the video i posted recently preparing
the staffer gamut from magnus carlson
so i'm pretty sure carlson had this like
same position
there's something really close
threatening this move now
hmm
that might be a novelty it's actually
not a bad move
wait now i have to think i was hoping
i was hoping for castling because then
there's a
kind of a cool trap um
wait this might be a mistake though
all right let's go in for the
the kill kind of
it's a competitive game so far so
there's two legal moves here
so i guess if you say an illegal move it
won't register hopefully
um chat going for the
not really a blonde cloud that's
probably the best move
if king f1 i would have played b5 to try
and win the pawn
um i have to be very very careful what i
say here
because i don't want to give away like
all my secrets
there's beef uh i guess i'll say the
moves i'm considering like b5
wait is material equal oh yeah i won
back the pawn so material is equal
[Music]
if i try and win this pawn
it gets messy
i might go for it i might play b5 first
like question the
the knight's purpose in life
there's also this move this move
actually
it's so weird looking from the opposite
side
uh i kind of like this move though
just developing
developing a bishop not doing too much
else
wink wink
it's actually it's fascinating to see
like the candidate moves
like e5 knight a5 queen e1
knight p2
um wow e5 very fancy
what is this position
i really want to go insane here
right it's actually
it's complicated because if i
oh i'm calculating 94 94
takes
it's playable actually
i think it's a really funny move though
i think i'll do it
it's such a funny move
and then i'll just leave chat confused
oh no my knight might only has two legal
moves
wait oh people figure out they can offer
a draw
no no no offering draws or resigning
um that's a valuable offense
uh so basically yeah the these were the
two legal moves
but this leads to the more hilarious
position
so now i can castle
i can castle or play rook team
immediately
i think i won the castle
the castle king queen skewer
very exotic tactic
these pawns are doing nothing to shelter
the the d-file
whoa it's zanian thraw with 520 bits
thanks for that
okay most people saying bishop d3
which does avoid losing a queen but now
the bishop's pinned
and i can decide do i want to take the
pawn or the knight probably the knight
it's actually really funny if we trade
here
then there is triple pawns next to a
neighboring pawn then there's potential
for quadruple pawns
unlikely to happen but who knows
yeah a lot of choices here
so king c1 oh
[Music]
the thing with king c1 the bishop still
pinned now to the queen
uh and three three different pawns are
hanging
how to do this maybe
maybe i should take here first
or maybe uh yeah i'll take with check
yeah no no quadruple pawns happening
this game
also no mercy
the center is now crumbling
so there's only a few legal moves i will
say my plan because my plan is kind of
unstoppable
is to play queen d4 forking the other
pawn in the rook
while keeping some pin
and so it's one of the issues with like
double or triple pawns they can't really
defend each other
they're a little bit clunky
not too many people listening to the the
ben feingold always play king b1 rule
okay so i can take this pawn or this
pawn
maybe i'll take this pawn
or at the other pawn
too many snacks i will only eat one
snack at a time
let's take this pawn
so i basically unleash the rook now
might be threatening to take this next
oh i see what's coming
i'm proud of chad like not giving up so
easily even though resign is the second
most voted for option yeah very clever
double attack
showing some fighting spirit
it's actually a good move
i could throw in this check
[Music]
what else to do queen g5
i might have to do something slightly
uncomfortable i think i'll start with
this
white now has three legal moves
i think there's drawbacks with all the
moves king d1 then their bishop's pinned
king here blocks the battery queen here
allows me to simplify
so you guys have to choose a
least of the evils
resigning ends the pain okay king d1 so
um yeah now the bishop's no longer
able to move legally so i was thinking i
could play b5
there's visual a6 there's crazy
unnecessary sacrificing
i think i'll play b5
it's kind of a nice it's usually wrong
to push pawns like near your king
but it's a nice way to undermine this
battery
reinforces the bishop and
now i'm threatening to take
oh chat wants to bong cloud now hey
we're going to see a bomb cloud
a very logical blonde clown but still
probably kind of bad
because yeah the bishop's pinned
by my bishop
and now chad will have to unborn cloud
or what is that song to the left to the
left or to the right
i forget
okay king f2 so now
i think i'll go for the trade
offering the queen trade while removing
the bishop
oh offer draw was closer what happens if
a
if it draws off and then i require
amazing love the content
oh you're amazing too block of winged
doors whatever that means
i appreciate the resub and willard the
gray
okay so we could trade queens
or we could have more fun let's have
more fun
usually you shouldn't trade queens if
your king is more safe than your
opponents like this king is way more
naked than my king
are there less people voting now i feel
like there are more people voting like
towards the beginning of the game
i feel like some people maybe did they
gave give up
um let me pawns them i'm up i'm up four
pawns
wait i was supposed to be the one
gamuting
what happened i i lost the only pawn i
lost was on move two
and then i guess chat played the counter
gambit
ooh interesting
keep everything defended queen is safe
this rook is kind of sad thank you
commander bun
selling a tier one
oh that's interesting offered accept
draw doesn't actually show the
number of votes it just shows percent
uh it's close to being first but not
quite
h2 is good because it tries to get the
rook into play
i could be mean here let's be mean
i'm gonna try and force the king back to
g1
or provoke g3
i guess the rooker queen can block
there's yeah there's a few options for
white
[Music]
uh oh uh oh
okay now i bond cloud with my queen
queen e2
yeah omega lol so there's two legal
moves both of them
get mated next move
impress no no like resign or draw offers
okay good game chat
that was fun oh chat versus eric says
i am rosen wins better luck next time
chat
yeah that was fun i hope people enjoyed
that
haven't done one of those in a while
chad actually played decently
um i have to estimate at a rating level
of
like probably 1800 to 2000
like the the plate wasn't so bad it was
just um
kind of gradually position got worse and
worse
yeah i think the computer graph kind of
tells the story of this game
like dubious opening and then
bishop e3 so there is a cool line
i was kind of hoping for i think the
second most voted for move was castling
which looks really normal because you
[Music]
you make sure this moves not a check
but then there's there's this move
bishop takes h3
or even knight g4 wait what's the best
move
yeah bishop h3
which i did have
in where was it
oh yeah so this video here
uh we can see the queen d4 move in the
thumbnail
and this was based off my prep for
carlson
an idea is after here here here here
oops don't mouse up
here here um
either knight g4 rook h6 i think is the
easiest move
or most understandable but or even this
and then knight g4 here
minus nine so
um so
i could show i don't know if i want to
show like the best move if you turn on
engine
engine will spit out the best line i
will say after
here queen d6 it's not easy to find the
refutation
if you've never seen this position
before and the point is still to play
knight g4
and white has to walk a very thin line
to get the advantage
so i think i'll leave with that
i might reveal more in the future
but uh yeah it's a nice line for like
blitzer bullet because
very often lock it's just my g4 idea and
there's all these mating ideas
um e5 is not the right move here because
we can take and
well it's a little bit too slow to
actually use a file like rookie one is
i believe just bishop e6
anyway that was fun special thanks to
i guess a few of the mods uh andrew
chess for
for making the spots i think brian was
helping with it
uh diamond cutter also probably
participating
um so that might go on youtube a fun
kind of
i had a dream where i got that from your
twitch last night
oh no well you're still
unbanned so your dream hasn't come
true yet
but all like dreams have meanings behind
them
like sometimes they're just things that
you you most fear in life maybe